institute for the support and health
um today we continue to have a very
interesting program of five
uh technical talks uh without further
ado let's welcome the first speaker
jacob anders from mit
thanks uh let me share my screen here
all right uh is this visible
yes okay great um so yeah hi everyone uh
thanks lee hong
uh my name is jacob andreas uh and i
work
on natural language processing at mit
um and today i'm gonna be talking
specifically about what we can do
with language data um in support of
machine learning or of reinforcement
learning applications
um and i you know want to start by
emphasizing that my main interest here
is language
our group is not focused on rl i'm
emphatically not a theorist um
but interested in uh as jl austin says
doing things with words and using
language data to sort of specify
actions that we want real world uh
agents to to take and
interact with things out in the real
world um and so i want to start a little
bit by talking at a high level
about what the intersection of of the
nlp in the rl worlds
looks like um and i think part of the
reason there isn't so much interaction
right now
um is that the approach to learning
problems is very
different than you know at a venue like
this the sort of prototypical
rl problem involves a single environment
equipped with a single reward function
and our goal is just to sort of heal
climb in policy space
until we get a good reward um
now there has started to be uh interest
more recently
in sort of dropping an agent into an
environment in which they observe some
description of their goal
rather than having to thrash around and
figure out what they're supposed to do
and now whatever kind of training signal
you get for learning this policy
uh at least sort of from an nlp
perspective looks like a normal learning
problem
insofar as there's a data set uh and you
can start to ask interesting questions
about generalization
um and in particular if these goals
specifications take the form of natural
language commands
then then just this just looks like the
learning problem that we know and love
in nlp
which is the problem of following
instructions and
if you treat uh goal specifications as
observations
uh these two learning problems on the
bottom are just special cases of the top
one
um and in this sense language can be a
super useful tool
for multitask rl it gives you an
expressive and flexible family of goal
specifications
you can elicit these goal specifications
from unskilled users
without special tooling which is a point
that we'll come back to later um
and you can plug them into your existing
rl approaches without having to think
too much about
like what the language is or what it
actually describes
now to the extent that there's something
identifiable as like a standard approach
to language and rl
it basically looks like this picture
that whatever linguistic annotations you
have
are just part of your observation space
they tell you what you need to
sort of get the reward that you want um
what i would like to suggest today
is that this picture is at least
incomplete and to talk about a couple of
other roles that language might play
representationally in the broader rl
landscape and in order to do that i want
to start by actually talking about one
of my favorite psychology experiments
and the setup for this experiment is as
follows we have a rectangular room with
clearly distinguished long and short
walls
and one of those walls is painted blue
so every corner in this room is uniquely
identified
by whether the long wall is on your left
side or your right side and whether
by the presence or absence of this blue
color we're then going to take some sort
of rewarding thing we're going to hide
it out of sight in one corner of the
room
um and the basic form of the experiment
we're going to run here is to place an
agent in the room
let them find the reward disorient the
agent and then see if they can find it
again
now if you do this experiment with rats
they're not very good at this task
a little less than half the time they do
the right thing otherwise they go to the
wrong corner or they give up
and the conjunctive aspect of this goal
location is important
uh if the rats just have to discriminate
based on position or just based on color
they do fine now if you take uh
pre-verbal human infants and you give
them the same task they're even worse
they're you know evenly split between
the spatial equivalent corners maybe
even a little worse than
chance and again ignoring the color of
the wall
now unsurprisingly if you run this
experiment with sort of normal human
adults
almost everybody gets it right but
if you then take these adults and you
hijack their language abilities by
asking them to repeat a prose passage
out loud
while they do this task they start
behaving like rats or pre-verbal infants
now this effect appears to be specific
to language if you give these people
cognitively demanding tasks that don't
involve language
they don't produce the same effect so it
seems that the language faculty is in
some way specifically implicated
in humans abilities to form
compositional representations of goals
in tasks like look that look like this
um and in particular
even four tasks that have nothing to do
with language
now i don't want to like overstate the
implications of this experiment for
machine learning obviously current
approaches to
rl where they're good enough function
approximator do just fine at these kinds
of problems
without being able to speak english but
these experiments do sort of suggest
that
language might be useful as a
representational tool
uh in the same way that people find it
useful and again even in those problems
that like this one we've been looking at
don't actually give you language as part
of your environmental observation
and so we're going to look at a couple
of different views
on this perspective of the problem
starting with language as a source of
temporal abstractions
for reinforcement learning now as a
running example on the next couple of
slides we're going to think about a sort
of minecraft style video game in which
you have tasks like making planks
that consist of steps like chopping down
on trees using a workbench
and so on now as we know there are
lots of reinforcement learning problems
uh that
involve high level actions where there
exists
temporally coherent sequences of actions
that an agent can execute
that cause a specific change in the
environment or accomplish a sub-wool
in a way that's useful either across
multiple stages of a task
or multiple tasks things like getting
yourself to the exit of the room that
you're in
or grasping the object that's closest to
you um
in one formalization of this approach
some policies that implement these high
level behaviors
are called options um if you have access
to the right set of options
they make rl a lot easier right the the
sort of long horizon problem
uh gets significantly contracted if we
only need to take a small number
of these high level actions but
automatically discovering options
is super hard uh sometimes as hard as
the underlying rl problem
and so there's correspondingly been a
lot of work on figuring out alternative
forms of supervision that we can use
for inducing these kinds of hierarchical
policies
um the simplest thing that you can do of
course is to manually specify subtasks
and provide some kind of explicit
subtask completion signal or other
intrinsic reward
um this makes learning easy at the cost
of making sort of annotation or reward
engineering really hard
another thing that you can do is to
collect examples of successful behavior
provided either by an expert or by
successful rollouts from the model
itself
and then try to segment these things
into reusable options
um this problem just looks like ordinary
learning in an ordinary
hidden semi-markov model and we can sort
of throw our structured prediction
toolkit at it and work and do pretty
well
so what role might language play in a
process
of option discovery well if you think
about what an instruction for one of
these tasks like get wood and then use a
saw
about what that instruction does it's
basically giving you
supervision for the top part of this
figure it's communicating something
about the abstract structure of policies
without actually specifying how this
abstract structure
grounds out in level percepts or actions
now this is obviously useful if you
already know
how to interpret these instructions um
but what if you don't
is this kind of linguistic supervision
useful
even to guide sort of rl from scratch
and what this looks like practically in
a multitask setting
is something like this i have say task
one
i have some high level instruction that
says first get wood and then use a saw
and initially my learner doesn't know
what either of these things mean
i have some other tasks that you know
gives me high level advice in the form
of get wood and then use an x
again the learner doesn't know what
these things mean but whatever this get
wood
thing is um it appears at the beginning
of both of these
sort of high level commands and that's
an indication that the beginning of a
successful trajectory for each of these
tasks
um should look the same at this abstract
level of representation
we're going to call these pieces of
high-level advice
policy sketches um and like we saw at
the beginning of this talk the most
literal-minded thing we could imagine
doing with these policy sketches
is just constructing a sort of single
fixed model say a feed-forward neural
net
that conditions on a representation of
the sketch as well as environment
features
this looks like the kind of instruction
following models that we have
in the nlp literature um but
taking inspiration from all the other
work that's gone on in hierarchical rl
we can also imagine using these sketches
to structure the parameterization
of our policies themselves and
concretely we're going to implement you
know a hierarchical policy
where there's a high level policy that's
just going to mechanically execute in
sequence
a low-level policy for each of these
instructions for each of these tasks
and then these low-level policies will
be shared across high-level policies
when the underlying instructions are the
same so this is ultimately just a
structured parameter tying scheme
where the structure of the parameter
tying is inherited from
a sort of co-occurrence in language and
i really want to stress how little
information
uh is communicated by these sketches
right what's on screen is literally the
entire file containing the extra
supervision we're going to use for these
crafting experiments
um you know many many fewer bits than
what the agent is going to get via its
interaction with the environment
um but even this tiny bit of extra
supervision used to do this structure
parameter tying
um makes a big difference so we can look
at this uh here's a more sort of fleshed
out example from one of these crafting
tasks
where the agent you know if it wants to
get the gold brick has to do things like
getting wood and getting metal and
combining them at a particular place
into a bridge and then walking across
the bridge
um and so on uh we also did some
experiments on learning
locomotion policies um and the important
takeaway here
is that language helps but specifically
that using language
in conjunction with an options policy
rather than just treating it as part of
our environment observation
um is what's really important here um
and this is true whether you have these
sort of discrete theme style action
spaces
or continuous control now so far we've
just been looking at
normal rl learning curves right our
agent gets to interact with the training
environment as much as it wants
it's going to see these sketches and all
of them and we're just trying to make
those lines go up as quickly as possible
but in keeping with the theme of sort of
using language even for problems that
don't explicitly involve language we can
also ask the following question
does this kind of pre-training give us a
good inventory of high-level actions
that are useful for new tasks even if we
don't observe any language at all
um and for context here are the sort of
final task completion rates for an
unsupervised auctions learner and a
learner with policy sketches on those
crafting tests we were looking at
earlier
um if we introduce a new you know sort
of similarly challenging task
with no language at all we can still do
rl
at the high level and still using these
sort of low level policy or some
policies that we learned from language
be able to explore very efficiently in
these new environments so language
plus this hierarchical framework lets us
bootstrap policy representations that
are good initializers
even for non-linguistic tasks now so far
we've been referring to the supervision
as language
uh the kinds of high-level behaviors
we've been talking about were in fact
very simple
the annotations that specified them were
basically discrete indicators
um does this generalize to what we think
about when we actually talk about
natural language um so here is
uh is this the data set that i want yeah
um is a an example from a
data set that was recently released or a
game and a
corresponding data set that was released
by some folks at facebook um
it's great it includes uh these sort of
hierarchical instructions where you get
high-level natural language annotations
uh for sequences of sub-actions that are
being executed by these agents as they
play
right so now there's a sort of
high-level command to build cavalry
that bottoms out in some low-level
actions and as a side note it's sort of
difficult to imagine how you might
elicit
this kind of hierarchical structure um
you know if you didn't have language as
a structuring device then in some sense
what makes this a good high-level policy
is that each of these high-level actions
has some sort of concise coherent
natural language description
now in this game of course we have a
much richer space of natural language
actions uh but we can repeat that last
experiment for
from our crafting game and ask what
happens if you use a model derived from
this language data
as an initializer and then do rl at the
high level and at the low level
uh and here we have much weaker
constraints right we're not constraining
the high level model to execute commands
and lockstep
but this pre-trained high-level policy
encodes a bunch of prior knowledge
about what sequences of language-based
commands are plausible
note this is still a sort of you think
of it as a semi-markov model
but now your space of options or your
space of like markov states
uh is indexed by the set of natural
language strings
uh sure enough even when the language
gets much more complicated language
helps a ton
you can learn quite effectively by sort
of jointly training this high-level
controller policy
and uh the model that interprets the
high-level instructions
uh i'm gonna skip this slide um next i
wanna briefly
talk about one more sort of generic way
of using language to guide reinforcement
learning
uh so we looked uh just in the last
section of this talk
at ways of using it to give us kind of
temporal structure in our policies
now let's talk about using it to
structure goals and let's think
back to this experiment from the
beginning of the talk
the fact that only adults with unimpeded
language faculties
can solve this task implies that
language is somehow
being used to construct or help
construct the goal representation
so what that what might that look like
uh in a machine learning context
well if we're in some sort of
environment where we know the dynamics
and we have the ability to plan
then the main problem that a
reinforcement learner has to solve is
just to infer the form of
the reward function um and if we're in a
multi-task setting
the learning problem is basically to
identify some space of goal
representations
and parameters for interpreting those
goal representations that explain the
rewards that this agent is seeing
on different rollouts for different
tasks and whether you're getting
feedback by
interaction or from a bunch of
demonstrations learning
you know basically reduces to inference
in this kind of model
um so then the question is what does the
space of goal representations look like
and nowadays there's a lot of work on
like visual goals where you just predict
the sort of image that you want to see
when you get to the end of the task
or sort of free to form goal embeddings
but of course it's very easy to set this
model
up in such a way that goals are natural
language descriptions
uh that while exploring our rl agent is
asking
how would i describe in language the
features that are common to all of my
successful trajectories
and the cool thing about setting the
problem up this way is that a reward
model like this
is up to normalization an instruction
following model
it picks up a trajectory and picks up a
natural language description
and tells you whether the trajectory
matches the natural language description
so it's easy to train uh from any
instruction following data that we
happen to have lying around
like we saw earlier in the talk and then
adapt to new tasks in the same
environments but where we don't have
instructions
by just doing inference over the space
of goals implied by those natural
language instructions now why might this
be a good idea
well there's tons of structure in the
space of strings that we don't get in
other places
language makes it hard to describe weird
maybe you sort of overfit sounding goals
like you want the third pixel in the
observation image to be this precise
shade of blue
so to the extent that we think real
world rl problems are going to involve
natural goals language gives us a sort
of natural description length
prior on that space of goals um
very briefly just as before framing rl
is learning
uh framing rl as inference of gold
descriptions you can do well at some of
these complex gridworld
rl tasks we were looking at uh you can
do this for imitation learning
where you wind up with something that
looks like programming by demonstration
where your programs now take the form of
natural language strings and the
interpretation the execution of those
semantics of those programs is learned
so
uh you know for for imitation learning
we have some fun experiments in the text
editing domain
as well um i want to conclude this talk
a little bit more speculatively
um so a common feature of the two
families of models
that we looked at today is that part of
the model is
a distribution over strings uh that
right in the options framework we have
some sort of high level policy
placing a distribution over sequences of
commands that look like sentences
uh in the goal inference framework we
have a prior over goals
that's just a prior over natural
language descriptions
of goals or of reward functions or what
have you
now if you've been paying attention to
nlp in the last couple of years
you've probably noticed that we are now
really good
at placing probability distributions
over natural language strings that is
possibly the only thing that we really
like know how to do anymore
uh but this we can do quite effectively
so you know we have these models with
names like bert and gpt
and elmo that learn to generate language
either unconditionally
or conditioned on other language data in
various forms
and if you take these models and you
train them on big text corpora
um they are able to pick up a lot of
information about how the world works
both common sense knowledge like the
color of our banana
um but more relevantly to our purposes
today information about the structure of
actions or transitions
in the real world like the fact that a
knife is useful for chopping a carrot
that if you drop a glass it will explode
um and one thing that you could imagine
doing in response is to say
okay let's then just encode the entire
world and text
and take actions by exploring as best we
can in those worlds
um those of you who grew up with a
certain era of video games will
recognize this problem that we've
described as a test adventure game
right where some human designer has
already gone in and built a whole
representation of the real world in text
and we just need to reason about
language in order to figure out what to
do there
sure enough if you take one of these big
pre-trained language models you
fine-tune it a little bit
you can do very effective exploration
and play in these text adventure games
but to take a step back here um
even if we ultimately care about not
these kinds of text games but about
taking actions in the real world
and we can't hope to write down these
kinds of text encodings by hand
we are still soon going to find
ourselves in a situation where we have
these ungrounded language models
just like distributions over sequences
of strings
that another nonetheless capture a lot
of the important high level structure
of like the mdp right the sort of real
world of things and agents
in which we all spend our lives in which
we want to build effective robots
um i think this is clearest in nlp but
we're not far from having
similarly rich models of vision and
video as well
and in this perspective the rl problem
that we in language
understanding like most desperately need
a solution for right now
is this i have an abstract model that in
some
like very coarse and very noisy sense is
isomorphic to the real world
but i have no idea about the actual
correspondence between pieces of this
model and pieces of the real world right
i know what a glass is i know if i drop
a glass it's going to break but i don't
actually know how to recognize when if
somebody shows me an image of a glass
so how do i efficiently discover that
correspondence or at least the pieces
that are relevant to my needs
as quickly as possible like how do i do
model based rl
when the model that i have is only up to
isomorphism
a model of my environment so i think
that's the big challenge for language in
rl
something we're going to be thinking
about a lot in the next couple of years
and would love to discuss with all of
you
um yeah and that's all i have if you're
interested in these issues a bunch of us
put up a survey last year on the sort of
nlp and rl landscape
and there's a bunch more pointers to
related work in there
thank you thanks jacob
yeah this is really interesting it
touches some of the corey susan ai
um now we have a few minutes and we can
turn floor
questions open for questions
um i see that you seem to have a
question would you like to
ask sure uh
hey uh yeah um i was wondering why you
said the talk
uh to what degree the fact that
uh you're using natural language is
important
uh so i'm thinking about that uh
obviously if your task is related to
you know like what humans would to like
place this cup here and there
and like finding natural text on the
internet and using that as background
knowledge is going to be important but
i was more thinking of of the the more
abstract level of like
okay i have a string of uh
i have a stream of strings and like what
properties should it have
how it should be uh you know like
feed it to the language or what not in
an abstract
sense to the task um
do you have any thoughts about this yeah
so
you know i think one answer is that uh
no it doesn't really matter that it's
natural language right that
in these like policy sketches
experiments we were talking about this
like barely qualifies as language you
could
replace these with sort of arbitrary
identifiers and still see the same
effects
um that being said you know like you
said once we want to start deriving
priors from uh corpus data online
uh the fact that these things look like
language is important
um another thing that we found like
especially in some of these
text editing experiments is that you
know this idea that you have like a
discrete space
of um
say goal or task specifications or
whatever and then a learn function for
interpreting them
sometimes lets you be flexible in ways
that um
sort of starting with something that has
formal execution semantics doesn't
so like for some of these string editing
tasks you actually do better here
than if you try to uh just do
like um
program induction uh from from these
examples
so i think you know i guess the
one question is is it important to get
uh
language versus some other like
ungrounded
structured description of what you're
trying to do there i think only to the
extent that a prior is involved
another question is would you do better
at some of these tasks if you started
with a language
were you like already knew the formal
execution semantics ahead of time with
something like
uh ltl or some more free form
programming language
and i think there it's actually not
obviously the case and that
being able to um
learn the interpretation of these goal
specifications is
buys you some amount of expressive power
all right cool thanks
um well i i have a related question uh
jacob
um in in your talk um when you have
language
sketches or hints for the policy do you
it has concepts like wood and stick
do you assume that these concepts are
known to the agent
beforehand so that you can map
efficiently map the
instruction to the real objects in the
environment
uh yeah no so for where are they like
for these experiments no
uh and you could certainly imagine you
know doing some sort of pre-training
thing or getting like image captioning
data for
for real tasks that involve these things
but yeah no the whole point here is that
you know nothing about the the semantics
of any of these instructions prior to
execution interesting
so so where is the uh the signal the
agent learned from
these instructions to map it to the
objects then let's say you get
then what how is different from get
forest
oh um yeah my question is um how does
the agent get
signal to learn to distinguish wood from
soar
and other objects so
here from the fact that it's a
multi-task learning problem and that
uh it's like shared by the prefix of
um of these two tasks or of the
the trajectories that you want to
execute for these two tasks
i see so so some kind of uh pre-training
or
transfer is required yeah i would i
guess transfer more than pre-training
and you know again like weight sharing
more than uh than anything else that
there's some
uh structural constraint that says
basically
like i'm only going to you know so one
set of experiments that i don't have
here is you can say
um let me give the agent now
like a sequence of these high level uh
sketch pieces that it's never seen in
that sequence before
uh can i learn to execute those
successfully uh
in other words have these like actually
disentangled the behavior that they were
supposed to disentangle or they all
totally co-adapted to each other in
these problems
uh you do a little bit worse in that
setting but still significantly better
than any of these bass lines
um and so you know i think the point is
just that
when and i think i only have like a good
uh sort of empirical account of this but
when you have a
multi-task learning problem like this um
you know like this one that we have on
the slide right now and you say
the policy for each of these tasks is
gonna like do the same thing in both of
these environments for some amount of
time and then turn itself off
and then switch to doing something else
that is enough
to actually like learn a shared reusable
behavior
for the thing that is shared between the
two tasks
thanks um we have a question from the
audience um
um jacob hdd so this is can the policy
sketches
uh with respect to hierarchical policies
and deep neural nets
be handcrafted uh for
which the text corpora is limited so i
guess the question here is could you
imagine
writing down um low-level
implementations of these behaviors
um as a surrogate for trying to like
learn them via
um uh via rl in the setting that we've
been looking at here
you know and i think that's basically
this picture right is can we
you know the hardest thing you can
imagine doing is like literally baking
into the weights of your neural net or
whatever
um an implementation of the getting wood
behavior the next easiest thing that you
can do
is build a like uh subtest completion
classifier
um and uh you know again the point that
we're trying to make here is just that
uh you can get away with much weaker
supervision uh than
uh or much less work than either of
these things if you just use this
ungrounded
um sketch information
i i do have a question but i let's see
whether um other people have questions
well maybe i can ask my question then uh
um
it's not completely related to this talk
but it seems that here you're using
natural language or some kind of
language to assist reinforcement
learning
efficient reinforcement learning but
there's also the opposite way where
people
use reinforcement learning to help nlp
problems in particular conversational
systems
which was more like that languages
applications
um could you say something about the
connection of these two are they
very different problems are they how
they they may
be connected yeah no so i mean they're
they're very closely connected to each
other and i think the
biggest or the clearest example of that
is
on uh these kinds of problems so
right here you have an agent if you just
think about the high level learning
problem
um that is taking actions in a string
valued action space
those actions are going to have some
effect uh here the effect is that they
cause a different
sort of low-level agent to do something
and then you get rewards based on that
in a conversational system those actions
like cause the
uh person that you're conversing with to
conclude that their request was
satisfied or to get annoyed and press
the bad robot button or whatever
um and so certainly there are
um generic things that you can imagine
doing to just like improve our ability
to do
exploration in these kinds of string
valued action spaces that would be
helpful in both of those cases
um another place where this comes up uh
is
you know if you think about these kinds
of games again um
one interesting question is once i start
to simultaneously
train the thing that's picking high
level actions and the implementations of
those actions
do those actually remain consistent with
the semantics of natural language
uh or not um and this is again a problem
you also have in these conversational
systems
insofar as one way of training a
conversational system without humans in
the loop which is really expensive
um is to just like set up two chat bots
and have them talk to each other uh and
there have been a bunch
of um
there's been a bunch of work on that
problem that's found in various settings
uh that you very quickly diverge from
anything that looks like the semantics
of natural language and you know these
agents just start sort of
sending gibberish gibberish to each
other uh that's somehow meaningful to
these uh learned policies but totally
incomprehensible to a human
um and so again i think you know one
interesting question here is when you
have
um these like language valued action
spaces
and you want to do rl in them what do
you have to do what constraints do you
have to impose on these models or on the
learning process or whatever
uh that allow you to like deploy strings
um more effectively while
remaining faithful to the semantics of
the language that you started with
i see cool thanks yeah um so um
yeah this is excellent thanks again
jacob
now i think it's time to move to the